okay people and we're playing a game  called dinner pile and I don't know they  know what this is about  so let's just do this oh boy oh my god  Chad Yvonne Jeremiah Diana's here  they're all here  oh my god okay oh why is bleep going  down what what the heck's going on here  oh do I gotta press her letters what the  heck has gone on here okay it looks like  the belief is going up Chang she says  our original Diana say Jeremiah ry and K  Cass by say this dinner is really a ruse  but the score was seven eight okay let's  just try this again real quick yeah the  heck is that okay  Thank You Tommy yes thank you okay I  just X head nice oh the world saucers  let's play and you hope you enjoyed it  very good sorry